so a lot of the problems I have with the
war on drugs is that people cannot walk
into a shop and buy something and know
what's in it no you know what is likely
to do there's no regulation whatsoever
and the supply chain behind that is
built on blood that would be illegal
market right if we somebody could do
that obviously you cannot do that and so
you've got you know ecstasy pills
because we're adulterated and kill
people that clearly wouldn't happen if
you had legal XE but Peters over looks
at and says oh well the fact that you'll
get a slap on the wrist for possession
of cannabis means that the whole thing
doesn't really exist and therefore any
argument you make about the harms of
prohibition is invalid because there
isn't prohibition there is some you know
the mere fact that you can you can be
done for possession actually people do
get done for possession particularly a
Class A drugs yeah they can have their
careers ruined actually quite quite
often and sometimes not very often it's
serve time in prison just for possession
you know possession was never illegal in
America under alcohol prohibition right
so the prohibition of drugs is actually
much more far-reaching than the
prohibition of alcohol was and it's
suffering from the same in inevitable
problems
how would a society how would you
envision a society where drugs are legal
would it be the sort of the Amsterdam
model where you go into a coffee shop
and you're picking at your weed and you
sit down and you smoke would it be
completely legal how would you go about
because licensing it and regulating it
well broadly speaking it would be like
this and you you would have I think
probably specialist shops is probably
the way to go so like your old head
shops before the government banned
legalize or used tobacco so a specialist
shop licensed but not restricted in
number you know some of the places in
America that have done this haven't done
it very well because they've turned it
into a cozy state-mandated cartel right
and so you get shortages and not enough
competition and they've banned branding
in some in some places and stuff I
wouldn't do anything I would have
branding I would have probably some
level of advertising I think politically
needs to be realistic
have a great deal of it but I think it
is important that there we have brands
because people know where they are
they're you know it's a real incentive
this is one of the things overlooked
when it comes to advertising to brands
there's a huge incentive for a company
to maintain quality and to maintain
their own reputation if they have a
brand that is worth a fortune if you
haven't got that if you just got
cannabis shops where you've got
anonymous pots of green leaves and
nobody really knows what is there is no
incentive whatsoever to maintain the
quality because no one knows where
they're getting it from so actually I
think you need to tap brands I would
have specialist shops for things like
cannabis I would essentially legalize
all the drugs themselves but not
necessarily every derivative that's the
thing so I don't think I would legalize
crack cocaine heroine for example but I
would certainly legalize opium smoking
and I would have opium smoking bars
obviously there would be no smoking ban
under my this is just your way to get
smoked crack in the door so yes opium
smoking now I'm not going to stop people
from you know making crack cocaine in
their kitchens
you know I'm certain it's not people
from growing their own cannabis and
stuff like that I just hope that if you
give people a much safer variety of the
drug essentially the variety of the drug
that was consumed circa 1880 mm-hm
alright so that would be smoking opium
rather than intravenous injection of
heroin there would be some form of
cocaine
I mean cocaine is a difficult one I
think most legalizes accept that cocaine
is a difficult one because I mean it
does play to your right irrationality
point right when when people are on the
stuff it's clearly very very moreish for
a lot of people and they don't
necessarily act in the most responsible
rational way however I as comedians who
have formed to audiences of some of them
have been on that yeah I think yes it's
so it's difficult but it is out there
already right people are already taking
London it's just it seems everybody's on
it yeah despite the fact is really
expensive yeah so I don't know cacain
was never used all that much issue
before prohibition
kind of associated with a few Bohemians
and actors yeah but it was used it was
mainly used actually in kind of patent
medicines and stuff and maybe that might
be the way more would we we look at the
drugs are being consumed to today ie
under prohibition and just assume that a
legalized market would be just exactly
the same drugs but sold legally I don't
think it would be like that because as I
said before prohibition has incentivized
suppliers to produce these drugs in the
most powerful and concentrated forms
[Music]